alright another run how was that for
your idea I was up for you you little
[ __ ] our dog trainer said it's good to
bring the dog out for a run anyway I
thought I'd blog today as and yeah what
I'm Jack come alone
it's really beautiful today but very
windy I'm not sure you hear anything of
what I say all right
something very special came in the mail
today what do we have here all right all
right all right all right Michael can
you help sure
well comfort - unboxing with PewDiePie
sent me this Thank You Lee I love Dark
Souls if you know me I love Dark Souls I
am so pumped for this oh god I think I
should just become an unboxing channel
clearly I got a talent all right first
up we get the standard dark cells fear
if you think this is cool you ain't seen
nothing yet
this might seem like a sponsored Dark
Souls there like vlog or something it's
not
I just love Dark Souls all right cuz
later we're going to do the Dark Souls
spicy chicken challenge there's a secret
compartment with the Dark Souls game we
got patches the art of Dark Souls a and
the map how about that holy [ __ ] that is
[ __ ] awesome he doesn't have any hand
stuff or a face it's like metal this is
version 1716 out of 2000 only so it's
exclusive and [ __ ] and there it is
[ __ ] badass yeah yeah toys for adults
it's pretty amazing figure I've never
seen a figure of this quality or I never
thought I don't want to
so to be honest today I was a little
bummed out because the the latest video
didn't do well which is fine but it's
like I put so much effort into it that I
really want people to see it cuz I think
it's really funny
although the comments were amazing so
this video demonstrates the reason I
wish Peter pine the random editing and
the random comments and rage and the
randomness just saw hilarious comments
like these that sometimes keeps it going
I appreciate it I wanted to announce a
new competition for the next Friday's
with bad bad I basically want you to do
any sort of PT PI fan art it could be
Photoshop it could be drawn it could be
a picture I don't [ __ ] know submit it
in the link in the description and I'm
gonna review it for the next do some wit
[ __ ] surprise me [ __ ]
I really enjoyed the videos where we
interact I think that's really cool and
it's a fun way to do it now I'm gonna do
some actual work and a lot of people
probably think that I just play games
but playing games is like the smallest
part of my day
unfortunately I have to reply to people
who wants stuff from me why why it's
again I'm probably just gonna livestream
or some [ __ ] anyway radda radda rat it's
lunch time I'm going back to eat with
Marcia and there's really no point of me
filming this beyond just making the vlog
more diverse buttes yeah [ __ ] in blood
while I'm driving
listen I got my hands in the wheels
don't you worry I'm an excellent driver
Oh God like Maya is so much smarter than
Edgar look at this okay Maya lead good
girl she's like yeah leak leak take it
you man
alright alright
food is here I always put this on my
sandwich since Kendrick
Arden thanks for kicking Mike soon this
is a park like a champion welcome to
Brighton where it rains every [ __ ]
single day all right
heading back to the office round two
all right everything is done sort of not
really but we have to go to the thing
now so let's go the fun the fun vlog
begins now
trust me what do you saw before oh boy
okay going to pick up PJ and Brad and
Michael today was a train wreck and more
like you two boys you probably didn't
notice it and you probably don't care
Michael yeah PJ wha Brad what the
chicken eating team has been assembled
you ready okay this is it we're going
yes
there's the challenge ye what Dark Souls
has to do with chicken challenge I don't
know and they got toilet paper
no 1s I do alright here we go
the point of no return what is it I
didn't read it what I understand the
risk of death no I don't shame of
failure that's all this is cross that
there will be no shame of failure
tonight community past got a few to die
oh this is cool guys I'll see you later
I'll see it I'm so scared
beautiful guys all right here we go the
manliest making dreams and then PJ what
drink do you
it can't be that bad I've eaten waste
place ourselves right DJ yeah yeah he's
gonna die I got my gloves for the
chicken
don't even think about the spice you're
doing it keep going don't give in now
don't give in to the spice Felix no keep
going oh my god this is amazing
you can come on you can win then I win
you can you should at least try to
finish because you wouldn't teach
you make a good point - there's a house
the spice is a little brother yes
a comparability really now it's just a
little burning yeah
the first thing is because my whole face
is covered in two bites and it's like
[ __ ] crazy but my lips are gonna
swell up and they're gonna read [ __ ]
awesome
this is amazing
Wow
caveman style physics what are you
accomplishing homeless man guys I'm
almost there I can't feel anything I'm
like destroyed this is my haters Oh
would you just eat some more oh god what
I need something to put in my life
we must concede but a little yeah their
lips are pursed lips like crazy it's
just which is where I can try the
Mustang
what is happening felt great I
definitely survived
is there a net zero test during the game
do you feel you're in knock so it's just
like one that one time I did a role in
Dark Souls and then George the boss and
I was like yeah that was cool
when I was six minutes when I'm how
stupid is it spicy guys
breathing
that was so easy oh boy let's do another
one
that was amazing to watch feeling oh
thank you hilarious
out watch okay but you did good you did
good you nailed it he nailed it okay oh
look we're playing PJs favorite game
look who won yes whatever he's a nerd I
know sorry all right
it's a new day had a lot of fun
yesterday you've got to feel the chicken
this morning not worth it I hope you
enjoyed the blogs and see you Bros in
the next video